today we'll recap my big visit to
Berkeley we will talk about a terror
attack in London and we'll talk about
Chelsea Manning being unfed
again at Harvard this time I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show if
I look a little bit tired it's because
I'm a little bit tired it was a late
night last night and I think an early
flight back so that we could do the show
for you here today and I'm gonna recap
everything that happened at Berkeley in
case you missed it because it was a lot
of fun I think that it was great I also
want to talk to you about this new
London terror attack thank god nobody's
been killed but 22 people were injured
when some terrorists we don't have an
identity yet but it looks like a member
of a possible terror cell put basically
a bomb in a bucket which is inside a bag
and then it blew up inside a trim but it
malfunctioned thank God and injured a
bunch of people but didn't kill anybody
we'll give you all the background on
that but before we get to any of those
things first I want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at quip so you know
one of the things that a lot of people
don't consider when they think about
brushing their teeth is that brushing
your teeth actually affects your entire
body health like there have been studies
that show high correlation between
brushing your teeth making sure that
your teeth are properly cared for and
things like heart disease well this is
why you need quip clip is a new company
that's refreshing the way people brush
their teeth it's an electric toothbrush
that packs premium vibration and timer
features into an ultra slim design that
is half the cost of bulkier brush is
very easy to travel with usually when I
have the the electric toothbrush that
was not quit then I couldn't take it
with me on the road clip is basically
the same size a normal toothbrush you
take it on the road with you it's
battery-powered and it's just terrific
you can subscribe to receive new brush
heads too on a dentist recommended
three-month plan for just 5 bucks
including free shipping because how many
times you've been at home and you don't
remember when's the last time you
actually replaced your brush head and
you just forgot about it well now equip
make sure that you get the brush head
when you need it it is backed by all of
the leading dentists it starts just $25
so right now go to get quick comm slash
capiro that is quip comm slash up hero
to get your first refill pack free with
the quip electric toothbrush that's your
first reap refill pack absolutely free
equip comm slash up hero get quip comm
slash Shapiro go check it out and again
when you use slash up here you get that
free first refill
that should take you for at least three
months beyond the original brush which
is pretty awesome so check it out
keep your teeth clean it's great okay so
let's start with the London terror
attack because that's obviously a bigger
international news than than what
happened at Berkeley so in London as I
say there was a terror attack it is not
clear who perpetrated the terror attack
as of yet
I don't think that would be idle
speculation to suggest that it is highly
probable that this was some sort of
Islamic terror cell the reason being
that this is exactly in line with the
sort of attack that Islamic terror cells
have done in the past that could be
wrong and as I say if it's wrong I'm
happy to correct it but the fact is that
we've had situations like this in the
past in London just back in late October
I believe there was a situation like
this in which somebody tried to bomb the
subway and it ended up being a guy who's
a new convert to radical Islam according
to the Sun Terre cops probing the
Parsons green attack have no idea who
detonated the bucket bomb that injured
29 so they've raised the number on rush
hour tube train today the Met Police
denied earlier reports that a suspect
for the cowardly terror act had been
identified using CC CCTV and you can see
a picture of the bomb here this is what
it looks like it's it's obviously got
wires coming out of it
whenever there's an explosion the first
thing people think is is it Obama
obviously this is pretty clearly a bomb
so president Trump immediately takes to
Twitter and begins tweeting things out
so this is where you know I agree with
Trump's general sentiment but I wish
that he would wait for more information
because he's the president I'm not and
me speculating not quite the same thing
as the president because the president
has inside information and so people in
Britain were a little upset with him
because here's what he tweeted another
attack in London by a loser terrorist
okay fine he said these are sick and
demented people who are in the sights of
Scotland Yard must be proactive it's
that second sentence that's a problem
for some of the folks in London saying
why are you giving away classified
information on Twitter right how do you
know that they were in the sights of
Scotland Yard he says loser terrorists
moppy's out must be dealt with in a much
tougher manner the Internet is their
main you main recruitment tool which we
must cut off and use better yeah well I
don't know what that means
but sure and then he finishes by saying
the travel ban into the United States
should be far larger tougher and more
specific but stupidly that would not be
political politically correct me
you should talk to the President of the
United States about that you know
somebody could actually promulgate an
order like that look none of this is to
rip on in Trump really because I think
that trumps general sentiment which is
that the West needs to get tougher on
terror is obviously true and I've seen
the left go nuts over these tweets again
I think the critiques I just gave of the
tweets are measured but real but they
have not gone not to over Sadiq Khan
who's the London Mayor who continues to
go out there and say things like
terrorists will not divide our community
terrorists will not ruin our
multicultural city again if that's your
top priority in the aftermath of people
nearly being murdered
on your subway then I would suggest your
priorities are not in order the fact is
the reason that a lot of people trust
Trump on terror is because it seems like
his priorities are straight he's much
much less worried about the
sensitivities of the multicultural crowd
than he is in finding killing
imprisoning terrorists and that's what
the government is there to do the
government is not there to foster
multiculturalism the government is there
to protect your right to life and if
they are not doing that they are not
fulfilling their most basic duty so for
all of the talk about how Trump is the
bad guy today all I would say is that
London has seen this is now the fifth
major terror attack in London over the
past nine months in the last 10 months
four of those five were Islamic terror
attacks and Tariq NAND and the head of
the the London Mayor City Khan has done
a pretty terrible job of tamping all of
that down insofar as he has the power to
do so okay so now to talk about the
speech at Berkeley last night so to lead
off I think that it's important to note
a few things first of all there's a
temptation on some parts of the left on
some parts of the more radical left to
immediately label everybody on the right
a white supremacist Nazi to justify
violence last night the City of Berkeley
and Berkeley UC Berkeley spent six
hundred thousand dollars on security for
this event six hundred thousand dollars
on security that's an enormous amount of
money that 700 police officers out there
lined up around the buildings they had
state troopers on call day they
basically showed up with a small army
and the reason they did that is not
because of me I'm not a particularly
threatening fellow I haven't been in a
fight since I was like 15 years old 16
years old okay the idea that I was gonna
show up at Berkeley and start shattering
windows uh Turley insane but in order
for some members of the radical left to
justify the sort of activity that
they've been
suing for the last year they have to
declare that everyone who shows up in
Berkeley who's slightly to the right of
Glenn Greenwald must therefore be a
terrorist Nazi sympathizer so one of the
people who said this yesterday on
Twitter was a guy named two Rican is she
who considers himself an anti-racism
activist Sarika she is also the dolt who
put out an anti racism it was an anti
racism organization with a logo that
looked exactly like the swastika and
everybody on Twitter started laughing at
him and then he got sad and took it down
anyway here is what he tweeted these
we'd suspected white supremacist ben
shapiro who tries to mask his racist
rhetoric by claiming to be jewish is in
Berkeley now hashtag Ben at Berkeley
yeah
there are a few things wrong with this
wait suspected white suspected by whom
of being a white supremacist by whom has
he liked has anyone watched this show
has anybody seen anything I've written
for the past fifteen years like white
supremacist what now and then he says
that I love this I'm trying to race and
mask my racist rhetoric am i claiming to
be Jewish man what a long con I have
going here
I really played the part you know going
home and not turning on my phone on
Sabbath and keeping kosher and all that
kind of it like boy I really I'm very
sophisticated in this comics is the best
way to mask your white supremacy is to
wear a yarmulke and keep kosher for
virtually your entire adult life that is
the best way to do it that's the best
way claiming to be Jewish really like
that's how the thing Patricia Heaton
tweeted back at him and she said I'm
pretty sure he's actually Orthodox like
he won't come to my Saturday night
dinner parties until after sunset and he
won't eat any of my food yeah but
everybody's a white supremacist right
this is the way it works
everybody's white supremacist here are
some pictures from the the the idiot
left students who who wanted to who
wanted to portray me as such yesterday
so they put up a giant sign in the
Student Union across the way from the
building where I was speaking Zellerbach
Hall and here's what it says it says we
say no to your white supremacist BS we
say no dear white supremacist BS which
is weird since I don't really spout
white supremacist BS and also I oppose
white supremacist BS but it doesn't
matter everybody's a Nazi
everybody is a Nazi and why not then
there are pictures of chalk right they
were writing things like F the police F
your donors you
or free speech kills really who died
yesterday anyone anyone if I had the
power to kill people with my speech boy
my life would be a lot better and also I
would definitely be targeting people who
are not at Berkeley like I'd start with
Isis
I started ice people were we're putting
out F ben shapiro of course which is i
mean frankly i heard that the office all
the time so it's not that impressive
also there's it's a free speech is not
hate speech well I mean honestly should
probably reverse that slogan hate speech
is not free speech because otherwise
doesn't make a lot of sense some free
speech is aid speech and vice versa in
fact there's no actual category of hate
speech that's something that you make up
there is hateful speech my favorite is
the pretty butterfly that they put up
there I really like the pretty butterfly
but there are some people who also
shocked on the ground Ben sharp hero is
not welcome well if he can't get my name
right I'm sure Ben sharp hero would be
very hesitant to come to campus but I
was not I was not particularly
intimidated by your chokings I'm sorry
but like what did they think that I was
gonna look oh there's chalk ooh some of
my favorite other other chokings were
the head of the UC Berkeley the
Chancellor of UC Berkeley's woman whom
Carol Crist and that Carol Crist her
last name is spelled precisely like
Jesus Christ and so they were a bunch of
slogans that were written down like
Christ must go and I just thought that's
gonna confuse a lot of people I mean I'm
sure that tell a lot of people at
Berkeley feel but that it's gonna
confuse some people so the protesters
showed up on mass and they had a lot of
silly things to say so here are some of
the protesters shouting after the police
which is just a charming thing to say
these are the people who the left says
her you know a lot of the left says
they're just wonderful and nice I mean
they weren't violence of what they say
is totally cool after the police
[Applause]
okay so they're shouting at the cops and
then this is my favorite the protesters
started chanting speech is violence
[Music]
speech is violence okay so then it's
funny cuz they seem to be engaging in
speech right there but nobody was dying
or being hit its speech is not violence
you stupid people
of course speech is not violence so
because of all of this as I said in my
speech yesterday the the fact is that
the speech is violence crowd are the
people who lend all the gas for the tank
of an Tifa because Antipa says speeches
violence therefore they get to show up
and burn things when people come and
talk which is just utterly asinine and
74 shows up where a lot of these people
show up and there's some crossover
between the two groups now I want to get
to show you the security arrangements
yesterday because they truly were
unbelievable I do want to compliment
Berkeley on their security arrangements
I think that they made some mistakes as
far as crowd control with regard to
people coming into the building that's
not the fault of the police but you know
they they ruled out the top half of the
auditorium we have over 3,000 people who
wanted to come well over 3,000 people
there a bunch of liberals who tried to
claim tickets and then didn't show up
and instead of handing those out to a
standby line of 150 or 200 people the
police instead seized the tickets so the
room which wouldn't easily fit two
thousand and we had three thousand
people who wanted to come and end up
being about eight hundred people instead
which is the fault of the UC Berkeley
administration but the security was
really amazing and I'll show you some
pictures in just a second but first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at the u.s. concealed-carry
Association so it's the middle of the
night you hear glass shattering it's
somebody at your front door and they're
trying to break in you go to your safe
you take out your gun here comes the the
intruder and you shoot them that's the
end of the story right well not so much
because when the police arrived they
don't shake your hand they put you in
the police car to take you away they
have to interview you interrogate you
they may arrest you even if you did the
right thing and that's why you need to
know exactly what you should and should
not say to the police it is the single
most important thing you can discover
today that could mean the difference
between freedom and a jail cell even if
you do the right thing especially if you
do the right thing go to defend my
family now doc
and over its offend my family now calm
you can claim your copy of the US CCA's
free guide that will uncover the six
things you didn't know what happened
when the police arrived and it goes
through all the things you need to know
about what to tell the police about what
you are likely to experience with the
police the six things you didn't know
what happened when the police arrived go
over to defend my family now DICOM you
get that for free it's like 160 pages of
good advice defend my family now calm go
over and check it out USC CA provides
you all the protection that you need in
case you actually have to god forbid use
a gun in self-defense okay so I want to
show you some of the security that UC
Berkeley committed to and good for
Berkeley good for Berkeley good for the
PD I can tell you how speaking to one of
the police officers yesterday and the
police officers were basically saying we
have been waiting to be unshackled by
the politicians for well over a year
we've been waiting for years to truly be
told that we're allowed to do our jobs
we've been waiting for it
I got I mean there's one one police
officer I spoke said a bunch of police
officers yesterday there there's one
police officer thank you to all the
police officers who provided a safe
secure place for free speech to flourish
one of the police officers said I got to
be honest with you like fancy four shows
up I'm not gonna be disappointed because
they were out in force okay this is some
tape of just the police officers
arriving to move around Zellerbach hall
the place where I was speaking look at
this
[Music]
if you look at this
hundreds and hundreds of police officers
and an Tifa couldn't do anything right
because all the police officers were
there as well they should have been and
tpho was stymied the police officers had
been told that if they if they saw
anyone with the masks they were to
immediately arrest them also you're not
allowed to carry weapons within a
certain radius of the hall so there were
nine arrests last night it's amazing the
police is saying well there was no
violence at this event last night it was
a peaceful protest imagine if there have
been nine people arrested at a tea party
protest and what the headlines would
have been it wouldn't have been peaceful
protests or largely peaceful protests
nine people were arrested last night and
this was one of the arrests last night
there is a what Berkeley side called a
big kerfuffle
a man shoved a woman and police
immediately rushed in and arrested the
guy there were nine people arrested I'll
have to show you at some point the the
clips the pictures of these people
they're definitely from among life's
winners there they're some of the
saddest looking human beings that you
have ever seen I hear is so the security
was top-notch and it needs to be
top-notch because this is what happens
if you don't nip violence in the bud it
grows and I hope that the security is
just as good next week when the
so-called free speech week shows up when
when folks like Milo and Bannon and
Coulter show up I disagree with them
strenuously I think Milo as I've said
many times is is a blot on the
conservative movement because he's not
particularly conservative and also
because he's a provocateur and says some
pretty terrible things but does he have
free speech rights in Berkeley you bet
your ass he does and I hope the police
provide him and the rest of free speech
week the same sort of protection that
they provided me I assume that they're
coordinating if they're not then then
the police should make that clear but
obviously if this is the sort of
security that's necessary in order to
preserve a free speech at Berkeley this
is the sort of security that's necessary
until it's no longer necessary it has
become largely necessary again because
what auntie Phil likes to do is they
hide in crowds there these terrorist
tactics they hide among civilians and
then when the time is ripe they pull a
mask over their face rush out do
violence and rush back into the crowd
and then they take off the mask and they
take off their jacket and then it's hard
to identify them the police were told
right away if there's a problem you grab
them and that's exactly what happened
there's no violence the speech went off
just fine and the speech itself I think
was it was fun I enjoyed it here's a
I'll show you a couple of clips from the
speech you can go to our YouTube page or
we have posted it and you can
watch the entire thing there are over a
hundred thousand people watching it in
live time last night simultaneously
it already has well over half a million
views here is a little bit of the
beginning of the speech where I talk
explicitly about antiva thanks to Antipa
and the supposed anti-fascist brigade
for exposing what the radical left it
truly is all of America is watching
because you guys are so stupid it's
horrifying i am grateful and you can all
go to hell you pathetic lying stupid
jackasses so yeah i didn't hold back on
them particularly but i also went after
the alt-right a little bit later in the
speech so the media is funny there's
some folks on the Left who continue to
maintain that I'm alright which again
you have to be an insane person to
believe this you have to be functionally
illiterate to believe this but I did
spend some time going after the all
right because that's the right thing to
do because all right white supremacism
is idiotic and evil but I think the the
clip that is the most popular today is
this clip of me debating abortion with
one of the with one of the students oh
we don't sorry we don't have that one if
you want to see that one then you're
gonna have to go over to our YouTube
page it's on our Facebook it's on our
Twitter it's going viral so you should
go check that one out because that one's
very popular maybe we'll play it on
Monday so we'll make sure that we have
it then but please go over to our face
but it's a good reason to subscribe to
our YouTube channel go over and
subscribe to our YouTube channel and you
can go see that particular clip how
frustrated what are the folks at Auntie
feh well this video is going around I
hope it's real maybe it's fake but if
it's not I hope it's real of a black
bloc guy trying to lift up a trash can
because he wants to hurl it through a
window he neglects to see that the thing
is bolted down to the cement
[Music]
since stupid and that was pretty much a
good summary of an tyfa's night last
night I do love that there was
apparently some girl who's asked by a
member of the media about counseling and
here's what she said she said just
taught this is Sofia Lee so young I
think this is pronounced and she is a
journalist for the for world mag she
said just talked to a Berkeley freshman
who said she'll be seeking counseling
after been at Berkeley event she's not
attending his speech yeah unfortunately
that's how it goes at Berkeley but I
think that it was a really valuable
event I think it showed the country that
we can have civilized discourse that we
can all come out against violence that
we can all rip white supremacy together
that there are still points of unity in
this country and that you do have to let
the police do their jobs if you wish to
have a civilized society you can't let
violent people run around and then
praise them as though they're doing says
that the Heroes of Normandy when the
fact is that they are nothing but a
bunch of street thug morons okay so what
Berkeley thing was it was a great I hope
it was an optimistic point for people is
an optimistic point for me I think was
an optimistic point for a lot of folks
right left and center who may disagree
with a lot of the things that I say but
recognize that there still rights to say
things with which I disagree on and even
on places like like Berkeley campus okay
other news so Chelsea Manning is
embroiled once again in controversy and
Chelsea Manning I do love this story
just a little bit Chelsea Manning was
invited by Harvard to be a Kennedy
School Fellow
okay to be a Kennedy School Fellow which
I don't know why Chelsea Manning wasn't
upset about the misgendering because
Chelsea man is in a visiting fellow
Chelsea Manning isn't a fellow Chelsea
Manning is a woman don't you know so
anyway it was announced that this
convicted traitor to the United States
was going to be a visiting fellow at
Harvard and immediately a bunch of
people resigned their positions at
Harvard over a bunch of the other
fellows including Mike Marella former
CIA director he said listen I've served
this country this person undermined our
country and is a traitor
I'm not gonna be called the visiting
fellow if this person's gonna be called
a visiting fellow so Harvard walked it
back they said we still want Chelsea
Manning to speak which is totally fine I
think that's appropriate and then they
said but we're not gonna say that this
person should be a fellow because it's
too much of an
honorific and there's been some blowback
on it so we're not gonna do that hey
here is what the Dean his name is
Elmendorf the Dean of the Harvard
Kennedy School had to say about he said
we invited Chelsea Manning to spend a
day at Kennedy School specifically we
invited her to meet with students and
others who are interested in talking
with her and then to give remarks in the
forum where the audience would have
ample opportunity as with all of our
speakers to ask hard questions and
challenge what she has said or done fair
enough
on that basis we also named Chelsea
Manning a visiting fellow we did not
intend to honor her in any way or to
endorse any of her words or deeds as we
do not honor or endorse any fellow ok
that's nonsense
hey I've been called I've had
fellowships at particular institutions
before I was for example a publius
fellow over at Claremont Institute okay
that was an honorific of course it's an
honorific they were idiots to give an
honorific to Chelsea Manning I speak on
campuses all the time without honorifics
okay it wasn't like they called me a UC
Berkeley visiting fellow last night I
was just a guy who came to speak okay
and Chelsea Manning is just a guy who
came to speak who is proclaimed a woman
by the media Chelsea Manning it was very
upset about this and tweeted in all
emojis I mean if you watch Chelsea
Manning's Twitter feed one of the
amazing things is when you see somebody
who's that gifted when the use of emojis
I know the first thing you think is I
wish I could take a class from that
person at Harvard Kennedy School of
Government I really wish that that
person would educate me in the use of
hieroglyphics because clearly this is a
person who's got it all together but
I'll read you Chelsea Manning's tweets
in just a moment first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at up
side so I travel an awful lot and when
we travel here at the Ben Shapiro show
we use up side it's great for business
travel particularly because it does a
couple of things one they have the best
available prices for flights hotels and
rental cars they also get you amazing
treatment because they they book all of
these things together they can bundle
all these things to save you a lot of
money and you get a gift card to places
like amazon.com every time you buy a
business trip the way that it works is
you set up your accounts on upside calm
you buy a ticket and then your accounts
is immediately credited with an Amazon
gift card for it can be up to hundreds
of dollars depending on the trip that
you're taking which is great I mean
you're using the company credit card in
order to book a trip and you're the one
who gets the kickback from Amazon calm
pretty spectacular they also have
amazing five-star treatment you get from
upsides customer service specialists
they call them navigators you're not
gonna be lost it's not like working with
some of these other
Travel websites where you buy the ticket
you have a question now you're screwed
you call them and they have people on
the phone available to you accessible
24/7 by voice chat email or message on
the up side app they'll even reach out
to you with useful info to help you
avoid a problem before it happens I'm
recently for example a navigator noticed
an up side user was booked in a middle
seat on a three hour plus flight the
Navigator automatically upgraded her to
an aisle seat with more legroom so I
mean they're really looking out for you
I mean this is concierge level service
I'm gonna start your up side six star
treatment right now go to up side comm
use my code Ben and you'll get a minimum
one hundred dollar gift card to
amazon.com that is code Ben for a
minimum one hundred dollar gift card to
Amazon's I come when you buy your next
business trip it upside calm upside calm
because you deserve a better business
trip there's a minimum purchase required
you can see the site for complete
details that's a pretty great deal use
promo code Bennett upside calm you get a
more inexpensive trip plus a minimum one
hundred dollar gift card to amazon.com
with minimum purchase so go and check
that out
okay so Chelsea Manning was very very
very upset about this and Chelsea
Manning tweeted out first of all I'm
just I'm always confused by Chelsea
Manning's Twitter handle like if you're
saying you're a woman then why is your
Twitter handle XY Chelsea which
technically means that you're a man at
one point I'm gonna have to go through a
full explanation for why biological men
are biological men and my biological
women are biological woman but I assumed
everyone had taken fifth grade biology
in any case Chelsea Manning tweeted out
honored to be first disinvited trans
woman visiting Harvard fellow and then
it's a weird sad / happy emoji they Cho
marginalized voices under CIA pressure
sunglass emoji rainbow emoji heart emoji
hashtag we got this genius I can't I
mean as a graduate of Harvard Law School
who went there because I got 176 on my
LSAT out of 180 and had an graduated
summa laude from from UCLA I know
then when I think intellectual caliber
I think heavy-duty intellectual caliber
I think Chelsea Manning Chelsea Manning
and then Chelsea Manning tweeted so
Harvard says Sean Spicer and Corey
Lewandowski bring something to the table
and add something to the conversation
and not me and then these the sunglass
emoji rainbow emoji heart emoji hashtag
we got this I don't understand what we
got this is supposed to mean
and I don't understand what all those
emojis are supposed to mean maybe
Chelsea Manning is just too
sophisticated this is why I need a
classic Chelsea Manning an emoji use
okay so am i a big fan of Sean Spicer or
poor Lewandowski particularly no but
they do bring something to the table
they are not traitors
they're not traitors to the United
States okay I don't like Corey
Lewandowski but Corey Lewandowski didn't
leak American military secrets to
WikiLeaks which was then apparently
utilized by terror groups
that's it they've got to step up on you
dude I mean like really that's let's be
frank about this okay Chelsea Manning
would still be in prison if it were not
for the fact that Chelsea Manning is
trans that is legitimately the only
reason that Chelsea Manning is out of
prison right now
the the opposition to Chelsea Manning
then Bradley Manning began long before
Bradley Manning identified as a woman it
began with the fact that Bradley Manning
was leaking American military secrets
thousands of pages of American military
secrets to the Russian front group
WikiLeaks okay that is that is why
people were angry and now after the
trans stuff that Obama tell we have to
let Chelsea Manning out because Chelsea
Manning's a hero a trans hero
everybody's a hero medal medal of honor
and now in and now Chelsea Manning
is saying that they're not bringing
Chelsea Manning because Chelsea
Manning's a trans woman no I would
guarantee you that Harvard Kennedy has
had trans women speak therefore as
fellows before if they have not I bet
they will in the near future I I went
there okay if you think that the the
nonsense the nonsense propaganda about
transgenderism does not dominate at
Harvard you're out of your mind of
course it dominates at Harvard but
apparently Harvard is now some
retrograde conservative bastion
incredible to me since I spent three
years there not one day and I guess I
just don't understand because I don't
understand why there's a rainbow emoji
in a Sunglass emoji and a hashtag we got
this
everybody's a child it's all childish
nonsense okay in other news from
president Trump continues to receive
blowback from the right over his daca
deal apparently one of the things that's
happening here is the John Kelly Trump's
chief of staff is basically limiting his
access to the news treating him like a
small child not allowing him to view
opposing points of view because it puts
Trump in a bad bad mood and then he
his opinion so he hasn't seen that Ann
Coulter is really going after him I mean
Ann is just on a rampage against
President Trump she's saying now that
she wasn't conned she says that that
Trump is a horse who didn't win place or
show even if she said yesterday that
maybe he ought to be impeached she said
this guy is like a couch
he picks up whatever the person sitting
on him is wearing so whatever hit was
his audience wants him to say he says
which is why some of us have been
concerned okay I like that and I've been
friend
friendly with Ann for 17 years I've
known Ann since I was 16 years old you
know
Ann is a very charming person when Ann
says that some of us have been concerned
like listen I'm glad that Ann has a
standard she has more of a standard than
a lot of people on the right who backed
Trump just because he's Trump but when
she says this is why some of us have
been concerned she wrote a book called
in Trump we trust that was the name of
the book eeep ler abyss awesome okay all
the people who say they weren't conned
you got to feel a little bit conned
right I mean they were there pumping
that we had to trust from you know Trump
was the guy that we had to follow Steve
King who again another person who I've
met and and I think Steve King's a nice
guy but Steve King was blasting Trump up
with all big Trump supporter very early
on congressman from Iowa here is Steve
King blasting Trump over the wall last
night on CNN so you heard him right big
beautiful wall and then today it's gonna
come later and now it's about a
renovation is the wall ever gonna happen
we were gonna have the Rolls Royce of a
big beautiful wall the first the first
section of that is inspiring to me to
hear that hearin the second part kind of
says that the Rolls Royce is now going
to be an overhaul jalopy
yeah that's pretty brutal from Steve
King there Tucker Carlson said the same
thing he said first of all points to
anybody who uses the word jalopy Tucker
says no reason that he has no reason to
be optimistic about President Trump on
this deal so Tucker doesn't trust him
either the president seems confident it
will all work out in the end but there's
no reason to be optimistic
the fate of daca recipients is by far
the best piece of leverage he has or
ever will have if he gives it away for
free none of his other immigration
priorities the priorities he ran on and
won the presidency with will even be
considered all those border security
measures
hearing about their ridiculous they mean
nothing they haven't worked and in any
case they'll be rolled back instantly
the next time a Democratic president
wins if this president doesn't get
funding for a wall now it will never be
built period okay so I mean tucker is
going after really hard there and for a
reason okay John Podesta
who hates Trump right John Podesta was
Hillary Clinton's campaign manager and
he's out there and all of his weirdness
saying that it's great that Trump wants
border protection we'd give him that
we'd love to give him some new border
protection for sure John Podesta last
night he met with the two leaders they
struck a deal and he should push forward
with it more border security in exchange
for making dock a permanent and that
would be good for those young people it
would be good for the country and I
think a majority of the public would
support that okay so it's pretty obvious
that the Democrats are getting what they
want out of President Trump and
president Trump is being given some bad
advice on all of this he continues to
maintain that he is going to that he's
going to push forward with this deal
don't worry there will be a wall later
now is it is he gonna lose his base over
this I don't think he is I really don't
think the President Trump is gonna lose
his base over this and the reason I
don't think that he's gonna lose his
base over this is because I think that
there are a lot of people who are our
follow-the-leader when it comes to
President Trump
there's a study very interesting study
that came out recently by a couple of
people named Michael Barbara and Jeremy
Pope at Brigham Young University and
here's what they said they said there
are there are a large number of party
loyalists in the United States their
claims to being a self-defined
conservative our suspect group loyalty
is the much more profound motivator of
opinion than are any ideological
principles they found that liberal cues
from Trump moved Republicans in a
liberal direction more so than
conservative cues from Trump moved
Republicans in a conservative direction
how big was the effect when Trump went
to the left more than 15% in a liberal
direction due to it from cue that means
that when Trump goes lefty on
immigration a bunch of his base will
follow him in fact they've measured how
flexible the base was on various on
various issues the base was least
flexible on guns and abortion those were
the two issues where they were least
flexible they were the most flexible on
immigration and climate change and those
are the issues and immigration
particularly is the area where Trump is
now is now moving so will he lose his
base I think that it's a mistake
to look at Steve Bannon or Ann Coulter
or Tucker Carlson and say these are the
people who are demonstrative of the fact
that Trump's gonna lose his base I don't
think that Trump is gonna lose his base
over this and I think Trump knows it
which is not a good thing right this is
the problem with with not following
ideas following people instead okay so I
quickly want to say thank you to our
friends over at tracker comm so one of
the things I definitely did not have to
worry about when I was headed up to
Berkeley is losing my keys the reason I
didn't have to worry about losing my
keys is because I have a tracker on my
keys the tracker device is a coin size
device you stick it on your keys you can
put it in your wallet and it beeps when
you alert it from your phone so you
never have to lose your keys again you
never have to spend half an hour looking
for keys then you're late to your
appointment because of it it's it's
really helped my marriage because my
wife loses her keys and her phone
particularly a lot it works in Reverse
too by the way one of the cool things
about the tracker program is that if you
hit the track or button and you don't
know where your phone is and your phone
is on silent we've all had this problem
the tracker program overrides that and
rings anyway it rings your phone even if
your phone is on silent which is just
terrific because how many times have you
lost your phone and then you can't find
it you're trying to ring it with
somebody else's phone you can't that
that's what the ring there that's what
sorry tracker is for that's what tracker
does tracker has changed everything with
the all new tracker pixel and you won't
have to worry about losing anything ever
again go to the tracker comm the track
arrghh comm it's tr ACK our comm the
tracker comm and for promo code BS to
get 20% off any any order that is the
tracker comp remote IPS my initials not
the other promo code BS for 20% off
again that's the tracker comm promo code
BSU get 20% off any order it will make
your life better it's one of those
little things that you don't think about
but once it's been eliminated from your
life losing your keys your life is just
significantly better in every single way
okay time for some things I like and
some things that I hate and then we'll
get to the mailbag so quickly a thing
that I like to been doing Disney movies
all like this one is a charming film it
has what Walt Walt Walt Disney called
his favorite single shot in the history
of all of his films in Cinderella here
is a little bit of the preview you will
have only to the stroke
and the spell will be broken and
everything will be as it was before
[Music]
it's like a dream a wonderful dream come
true
[Music]
Cinderella is that in the area
you tend to think of her as pretty
milquetoast character Cinderella but in
this film she gets kind of sassy with
the step with the stepmother a little
bit and it's it's rather charming it's a
single favorite shot which we didn't
show in this preview is there's the shot
where she's wearing her torn dress
because the stepsisters and stepmother
of torn up her dress and then the fairy
godmother shows up and you see the
magical bolts come from her wand and it
goes all the way up and around her dress
and then it comes down and when it comes
down she's wearing a new dress and that
was Walt Disney single he said that was
a single favorite shot in all of his
movies so that's kind of a cool thing
okay
yeah there it is we can show that that
shot that's that's anything um so here's
the shot can we play that yeah there we
go this shot it's a beautiful shot very
cool so okay other things that I like
when Tucker Carlson dismissed an aunt
Eva professor who was apparently half
giraffe on his show and it was pretty
amazing here was Tucker going after a
person who must be in the Guinness Book
of World Records for longest neck in
human history I mean this is it's pretty
that's it it makes you think that
Lamarckian evolution versus Darwinian
evolution is real then one day he saw a
tree outside his house wanted to eat
from and just stretched but here is here
is Tucker Carlson going up against an
Antipa professor these rights know my
position is that communities have the
right to defend themselves against
groups that actively seek to eliminate
members of that community to defend
themselves against violence or violence
I mean we were talking about it but no
but physical violence so a about
a history a group that has a history
like we're just we're we're suddenly in
this a historical world where we're not
killing roof or way Michael Page doesn't
exist we're unders Breivik doesn't exist
are you kidding me no are you really a
professor by the way what does Richard
Spencer have a right to speak in public
Richard Spencer is a danger to society
when he speaks in public what he is
doing he is publicly recruiting people
to his very violent movement very
violently so does he have a right to
speak in public I don't think he has a
right to speak in public unopposed and
that is ultimately what the purpose of
an Tifa is is to show and oppose
him but it's not opposition you shut
people down you prevent them from
speaking and you commit violence against
them I know a number of people don't
tell me I know people have been knocked
down and beaten by people from antifa
so that is true it does happen we have
it on tape we just roll the tape
so you're saying is that justified yes I
believe that communities have the right
to defend themselves against threats to
them so their community ideas they don't
like no I explicitly said that they want
to eliminate those people from our
society even inflating you're conflating
violence with ideas no if I raised my
hand to strike you you have no right to
straight you have to be put in order to
raise your hand to strike me you have to
think that you're gonna strike me and
when you when you are going out in
public as a protester explicitly saying
that you want to eliminate most of the
people from this country I believe most
of the people in this country have the
right to say no that's not okay okay but
it's you're absolutely right to say it's
not okay what you don't have a right is
to prevent me from saying what I think
even if you disagree and you definitely
don't have a right to commit violence
against me and you're blurring the lines
there and by the way don't you work at a
criminal okay you don't have the right
to do that you have the right to make a
character but eventually this professor
and went loping off to the savanna to to
graze with the rest of the herd so
Tucker Carlson went on Safari and and
bagged himself a giraffe so oh I want to
talk about some things that I hate and
then we'll do the mailbag but first you
have to go over to Daley wire and become
a subscriber for $9.99 a month you too
can become a subscriber you can part the
mail back today if you go on and use
your credit card really really fast then
you can be part of the mailbag right now
because we do take live questions on the
mailbag we by the way are having a
special Town Hall Q&A on the web site
next Tuesday you'll get to be part of
that as well when you go and subscribe
for $9.99 a month you also get Michael
Moses show you get Andrew Clavin show I
get to be part of their mail bags as
well which is pretty cool plus you will
also get the website without ads you get
to listen to our show later without ads
if you want and if you get the annual
subscription you got this the very
finest in all beverage
Souls this thing I mean let me just tell
you the power that flows through you
from holding this vessel you think I'm
very good at debate there's only one
reason for that because I once held a
leftist here's hot or cold tumblr that
we produced five seconds ago you need to
go get it for $99 you can you can have
one of those and you will enjoy it the
rest of your days so go over and
subscribe or go to youtube make sure
that you hit subscribe to youtube watch
you can watch the videos from Berkeley
last night all of them are interesting
and good now so go check that out we are
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
okay time for a couple of quick things I
hate that we'll do some mailbag so the
first thing that I hate is there's a
host who is a named Anthony Bourdain and
Anthony Bourdain I am not a fan of I
think his show is not good he goes
around to various places and taste their
food and talk about how wonderful book
culture is and generally their food is
garbage and so as their culture in any
case here is Anthony Bourdain and he was
talking in he was talking in some weird
way about what he would feed to
president Trump and he was cornered by
TMZ I guess and he was asked what he
would serve Trump at North Korean
dictator Kim jong-un at an imaginary
peace summit and here's what he had to
say
if Trump and Kingdra moon you're gonna
have a bit of a summit to find men
relations and they want to do Takeda
whoa disturb him walk okay hemlock and
then he says he's joking
hemlock of course is poison so he'd
poison both of them well what a what a
charmer he is because trumping him
jungling are exactly the same
yet another CNN host you can't contain
himself right on the heels of Kathy
Griffin with her beheaded trump mask
good times okay other things that I hate
Floyd Mayweather came out yesterday and
he was praising Trump's with what they
called locker room talk during the
campaign he said it's great because he
speaks like a real man he speak like a
real man spoke romance be like man she
had a feta see yeah
I had to squeeze her at a great I had to
grab a fat right girl was talk to him
privately about grabbing the ground but
just so he talking like I mean to talk
I'm in black home talk mmm I'm a man I'm
saying you know I am bi great about me
so I think that we should all be
concerned when Floyd Mayweather is
complimenting the presidents of the
United States on his manliness
Floyd Mayweather in a five-month span in
2001-2002 pled guilty to two counts of
battery domestic violence in November
2003 he was arrested and charged with
two counts of battery for allegedly
fighting with two women at Las Vegas at
a nightclub he was later convicted of
misdemeanor battery ordered to serve a
hundred hours of community service
according to the AP one of the accusers
testified that Mayweather punched her on
the cheek and then punched another woman
on the back of her head as used to her
she tried to help in December 2011 he
pled guilty to one count of misdemeanor
battery domestic violence no contest to
two counts of harassment for hitting the
mother of three of his children now how
many kids he has or how many mothers
they have he was sentenced to 90 days in
jail and released after 60 when Floyd
Mayweather is complimenting you on your
manliness let me suggest that you're
doing something wrong
okay it's that simple okay time for some
mailbag so let's jump right in James
says I've seen a lot of Millennials make
the argument that conservatives have
outdated morals do morals get outdated
or is this just an excuse for the left
to engage in moral relativism it's
definitely an excuse for the left to
engage in moral relativism the the idea
that morals become outdated morals are
based on the on the vagaries of human
nature on the evils of human nature and
morals do not become outdated just
because you think that you have come up
with a reason not to engage in the
morals now does not say that morality
has not
the way people see morality has not
evolved obviously I mean slavery was a
thing in virtually every society up
until the last 200 years that's one way
in which morality evolved but to say
that all morality is outdated you need
to explain if you're gonna change a
moral you need to explain why the moral
needs to be changed and really what is
the inherent value in the morality
itself so as I've said before I think
that the G K Chesterton line here about
morality is is pretty much right but if
we're seeing the right and the left is
that when it comes to changing morals
for example think of the think of
offense that you find in the middle of a
field the left the person from watt says
this fence has no reason to be there I
may as well just get rid of it the
person on the right says listen until
I'm not gonna let you get rid of it
until you explain to me why it's there
in the first place
think why an institution is there in the
first place and then think whether you
should get rid of it you need to
understand why something is there in the
first place
I don't think that conservatives have
quote-unquote outdated morals I do think
that that is an excuse for the most part
by people not to evolve morality but to
get rid of it entirely in favor of what
they think is moral as a religious
person I couldn't think otherwise I mean
I think there is such a thing as an
eternal God who creates an eternal an
internal moral code for for human beings
Ryan says hey Ben with all that's going
on in the debt ceiling debate would you
please clear this up for my friends in
me does the debt ceiling give the
government permission to spend money or
doesn't give the government permission
to pay back money it has already
borrowed thanks Ryan so it gives them it
gives the government permission to
borrow more money to pay off the money
that it's already borrowed okay so so
government is in debt right and we have
to pay off the debt well how do we pay
off the debt we can't just raise taxes
and take people's money without an
active legislature the debt ceiling
allows the government to borrow more
money in order to pay off the money that
it's already borrowed sell more bonds in
order to pay it's basically think of it
this way you have a credit card you have
a credit card bill that's due you don't
have any cash in the bank what do you do
you go find a 0% APR credit card you
transfer the balance from your first
credit card to the 0% APR credit card
and then you try and make a living and
then pay it back that's what the debt
ceiling really is so does the debt
ceiling have to get raised it has to get
raised unless you're going to
immediately cut expenditures but is it
also something that should be used as a
leverage point in order to cut future
government spending I believe it is
Jacob says what is your view on the
privacy versus security debate and how
do you feel about the sentiments of
tradition being used to fill voids in
the Constitution well you know
when it comes to filling voids in the
Constitution my general view is that you
have to rely on the people of the United
States to fill those voids as opposed to
trying to rewrite the Constitution in
the name of your own personal values
like Jacob suggests Griswold versus
Connecticut and Bowers V Hardwick and
roe v wade Griswold versus Connecticut
which is a ruling that says that
contraceptive use is a private thing and
therefore it's protected by the
Constitution there's two questions
you're asking one is constitutional
question and one is a question about how
I feel personally about privacy versus
security I don't think the state has a
role in regulating what you do inside
your bedroom that's not the same
question as whether the Constitution
prohibits a state from invading that
space and the answer to that is that the
Constitution is silent about whether a
state can ban contraceptives for
unmarried couples for example so that
means that the state can do that under
the Constitution now you may have a
state constitution that says differently
but this is why and a republic you have
a legislature if you don't like that
policy elect people to over overturn
that policy Nathan says hey Ben my wife
and I have been trying to have a baby
for some time it looks like we'll need
to go the route of IVF my concern is
that part of the IVF process is
fertilizing a significant number of eggs
which means we'll either need to have
many babies or eventually destroy the
excess fertilized eggs I'm not sure if
the moral thing to do here is I'm
extremely pro-life but also pro a happy
wife thoughts well here's my thought you
know IVF is morally complex because the
obvious intent is to create a child
might kill one but if you believe that
life begins at conception then that
means that you are better off from moral
point of view using in vitro to
fertilize say as many babies as you're
willing to have at one time and then
some of them will implant some of them
won't but what you shouldn't do is is
you know if fertilized certain number of
eggs and then kill something off
purposely because you don't want to use
those eggs now that seems to me to be a
serious moral quandary Daniel says do
you think all great empires or
civilizations fall for the same reason
if America ceases to exist at some point
in the future what do you think would be
the primary factors of the downfall well
no they don't no fail to exist for the
same reason but reality basically hits
all civilizations and depending on how
the civilization is constructed it hits
the civilization in a different way if
America ceases to exist I think the
primary factor in the downfall would
probably be the overreaching government
the overreaching federal government that
sees fit to in
all of our lives and all of our money
and all of our property ownership and
all of how we run our businesses I think
that will cause the collapse because
people will simply not want to abide by
those rules
Josh would say hey Ben I'm a nerve how
do you feel about asking for the
father's permission before proposing
Thanks okay so if your fiancee wants you
to do it do it I feel I have to say this
is one area where I may have changed my
opinion because I am I'm now father so
it is that sort of change things I
remember my wife really wanted me to ask
her dad's permission as a traditional
thing because her dad is Moroccan
Israeli and she thought it would mean a
lot to him and I really was was annoyed
with it because it's like you're old
enough to get married what happens if he
says no he doesn't know I'm still
marrying you so what's the point of this
little charade but as a sign of respect
I think it's probably a good idea so you
should probably do it Daniel says hey
Ben if you have to choose a country to
live in that wasn't the USA or Israel
where would you choose to live well I
mean I really only want to live in the
United States I think that Australia I
like english-speaking countries to be
honest with you
Australia Canada Great Britain Italy
some beautiful country I really like
Italy a lot Italy is a really pretty
country there are there a lot of but I
have to have to admit that my I'm not
the most well-traveled person I've been
to England and I've been to I've been to
France and I have been to Italy but that
is about it outside of the continental
United States and in Hawaii I also I was
in Israel for my wedding okay let's see
Clayton says do you think religious
leaders should openly share their
personal political views on specific
issues or candidates on platforms like
Facebook and Twitter or is that
unethical well I don't think it's
unethical I think that it's actually
good to know where people stand
politically what I do think is unethical
is for religious leaders to actually
hide the religious point of view on
political issues that is unethical the
whole point of religion is to help
promulgate values politics have a values
intersect very often and if you are
hiding politics in religion in order to
not alienate some of your group that's
because you're doing a bad job as a
religious leader Thomas says should new
parent such as myself be worried about
sending our young children to public
schools
pending the recent news of gender
swapping indoctrination and other
far-left ideals that seem to be growing
in the public education system is
private or homeschooling the way to go
listen I've always felt the private or
homeschooling is the way to go if you
can afford it or if you can spend
time there been a good public schools by
the way I went to public school that was
really great called Edison Elementary
School in Burbank I went to one that was
not as great called Walter Reed in North
Hollywood but I'm not saying that all
public schools are equally bad but I
would obviously be worried about the the
way that the public school system is run
with respect to the values it
promulgates jackson says hey Ben do you
believe there's a way for people in
sports to protest what they believe
without it being seen as disrespectful
by the public yes don't attack general
symbols with which we all agree there
are plenty of ways for sports figures to
come out and say listen I think that
this is an injustice and then we all go
okay all right well that's what you
think that's fine but when you kneel for
the national anthem that is a symbol of
unity for the United States when you
kneel at the side of the flag that's a
symbol of unity and there's nothing to
the sports or not sports I would suggest
however that you know if you if you are
a sports figure and you want to get
political you should know that comes the
cost because you are stepping outside
your area of expertise just as if I were
to step into the sporting world I
wouldn't expect a kobe bryant would
allow me to sink jumper after jumper
without blocking me okay the fact is
that's not my venue politics is my venue
if you're a sports person you step into
my venue you're on my turf now Brad's
has been what is your next book about
you know what I'm gonna save that one
because I'm working on a proposal let's
say I'm hoping that it will be my magnum
opus it's sort of my broad view of life
and the decline of the West so if that
titillates you then prepare yourself
it'll be ready in 16 years no I should
be having I should be making that
proposal pretty quickly and then I'll
tell you all about it as soon as that is
clear okay so we finally made the
weekend long week guys but we will be
back here on Monday with much much more
I believe I'm off the end of next week
is the end of next week is Rosh Hashanah
so it'll be a bit of a truncated week
for me on that and so make sure you're
here on Monday to get all of the news
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
[Music]